uh
gave you here was a high-stakes
situation but there are many algorithms
right now that decides our everyday
decisions they tell us
what to read what to watch
what to buy and even whom to date
so they are influencing us however they
are still hidden in black boxes
and i'm not going to say that the black
boxes are bad they are here for many
reasons so they are here to protect
intellectual property of companies they
are trying to prevent malicious users
from gaming the system and more
importantly they try to provide users
with an easy and effortless interaction
with the system you don't want to
overwhelm users with all the details of
an algorithmic system because it's not
even comprehensible for even some
developers of the system but today i'm
going to try to show you that while
black box design as a traditional design
particularly in human computer
interaction
look uh look helpful for users in many
cases it can actually cause some
misinformed behavior and i'm going to
show you that this misinformed behavior
doesn't happen when there is bias like
my case there are cases that there is no
bias in the algorithm but still it can
cause misinformed behavior so a few
years ago a large group of facebook
users started to build an app that
actually could block automatically
moms posts about their babies or like
pictures of that that they don't see
that they say they're kind of exhausted
with seeing a lot of moms posting their
newborns babies pictures
however meredith morris who actually was
a new mom that year
started uh
questioning this assumption that new
moms actually increase their activity
and posting a lot of babies photos so
she did some research and she found that
actually mom's particular new mom's
activities on social media decreases
very significantly after the baby's
birth for at least a year or two and the
question was that who caused this
misperception because many of these
users either blocked their friends who
were moms
manually or via that app
and she found that there is a facebook
newsfeed curation algorithm that tries
to filters or prioritize posts in
people's feeds and one of the reasons
and one of the uh
ways that they the algorithm works is
that it considers the number of like
attentions like in terms of likes or
comments the posts get and photos of
babies usually get a lot of comments or
post particularly newborns because they
are events life events that also
kind of affects the algorithm and that
algorithm then shows these posts over
and over and prioritized on people's
feet giving this perception that these
moms like are acting very actively in
the system however many of these users
lack of awareness
about this kind of manipulation on their
feet created this kind of
miscommunication between their friends
and themselves and affected their
interaction with each other so the
question is that how we can resolve or
at least mitigate such misinformed
behaviors in algorithmic systems
during recent years there have been a
huge literature
uh on how we can detect bias or
discrimination in algorithmic systems
how we can
create further or more comfortable
algorithms
but something that is
less understudied
less studied and understood here is the
role of design so
meaning that how designing an opaque
algorithmic system can actually affect
user's interaction with the system
and what are the roots of the
misinformed behavior because of the
opacity of this
algorithmic systems so in this talk i
try to convince you by walking through a
series of projects to show you that
while designing these algorithms and
making them as much as unbiased as
possible is very important it's as
important if not more to build a proper
communication between users and this
system because if they don't know there
is an algorithm or if they know there is
an algorithm they don't know how it
works as much as they need to know
they can have a good communication with
the system and it can still cause
misinformed behavior
so to do so my goal is showing that how
we can design some algorithmic uh
kind of redesigning algorithmic systems
that add transparency and inform
interaction with users without getting
in the way of the users so that's the
main important thing here is that being
an important thing because if users
become overwhelmed with transparency or
like what's going on in the system their
interaction again would be interrupted
and in this talk i'm going to show you
through three series of projects i've
done during my phd as a few steps
towards getting to this goal the first
step as you can guess to understand how
we can build a better design
uh
for a user's interaction between
users and algorithmic systems is
understanding how users currently make
sense of these algorithmic systems
and then
i'm going to show you in the next two
projects that now how we can help users
to have a better algorithm sense making
with the systems by designing for that
and also finding the right level of
transparency how much we want to give
users information about what's going on
inside the black box
and through all these projects i want to
show you that if we add enough
transparency which i'm going to tell you
how
uh it can mitigate misinformed behaviors
uh or like
interaction between users and the
systems and help users to become more
adoptive and intelligent
so as i said at the first step we need
to know what's the current state how
users make sense of these algorithmic
systems in the what
so for that we need to find
first what are the algorithmic impacts
and then how use how users behave around
these impacts and how we can understand
how they understand the system
and uh in terms of uh understanding the
impacts of algorithmic systems i'm going
to use bios as just the case so this
talk is not about bias while it's very
important and i've actually worked on
many projects about this but the focus
of this talk is
on algorithmic interaction between users
and algorithmic systems and bios is a
kind of an algorithmic impact which
people define as an inclination or
prejudice for or against a group of
stakeholders in a system then it's
considered to be unfair
and i'm gonna
use algorithm auditing as a way that
during recent years has been used to
understand the top the different biases
an algorithmic system can have
uh so today i'm going to talk about at
this part of the talk i'm going to talk
about the rating
platforms
uh and their algorithms because they are
a group of socio-technical system that
are very powerful in deciding the
success or failure of a business
and what they do is that they use
algorithms
to determine like the rating of a
business and let me uh
tell you like how powerful these
examples are for example here
uh research has shown that
uh only a half a star of change in a
yelp rating which is decided by the
rating algorithm on yelp can determine
the success or failure of a restaurant
by three thirty to forty percent
uh
likelihood so
the question is that how these
algorithms work so
this rating algorithm as one can
imagine we think that they just get all
the ratings of users as input and just
calculates an average but that's not the
case in most of the systems for example
here amazon says that look we have an
algorithm that considers many factors
to determine the final rating of an
algorithm so if a product on amazon has
a 4.5 it's not an average of all the
users inputs it's a
it's a kind of a machine learning
algorithm that considers like for
example the age of the review if it got
helpful votes or if it's actually
verified purchase and many other
features that you don't know how they
are
uh working together to
build a final rating
but like many other opaque algorithmic
systems because these are these
algorithms are opaque we don't know how
they work and there are many legitimate
reasons for that for example not gaming
the system
users argue that these algorithms could
be biased and can actually hurt their
businesses particularly those who have
small businesses and these algorithms
are really powerful
so one of these algorithms that
i had an initial initial investigation
and i found that there might be a bias
in them is booking.com how many of you
heard of booking.com
okay nice almost everyone so it's a
hotel rating platform it's actually the
largest iterating platform in the us
that people use to find and book hotels
and i'm gonna show you
what that initial investigation showed
this is the interface that if you
purchase the hotel via booking.com you
are allowed to use to raid the hotel and
as you see is that you give a ratings to
different features of the hotel and then
it calculates a final rating and the
ratings in hotel uh platforms are
usually between one and ten and that's
kind of a norm between this
and
what you see here is that if you give
everything the lowest for a hotel it
goes to 2.5 not one
however in the main interface it always
says it's from one so as you see it's
just categories from one to three is
very poor three to five and up to ten
and what this kind of
uh
rating is going
caused is that
many
reviews that are supposed to be in the
very poor
on the right side they go actually to
poor or like higher because the 2.5 is
the lowest so most of them actually get
skewed up to three which is uh under not
very poor area
so i was wondering that do users know
about that and also how this actually
affects hotels ratings does is it just
maybe a miscalculation of the minimum
does it skew everything up up to 10 that
they can
so i did some research and
i collected uh hundreds of hotels
ratings on booking.com and some other
competitors like uh expedia or
hotels.com and a few more i'm going to
show you just a few of them
and as you see there if you look at the
ratings so this blackline is booking.com
and these are the hotels and this this
is the ratings of the same hotel on this
chart as you see
for those who hotels that are like kind
of under seven rating that they are
called in the hotel industry as medium
hotels or low to medium quality hotels
their
kind of ratings screwed up like to about
37 percent meaning that if you are on
booking.com and you look at a hotel that
it says a 7 from 10 it's actually about
5. it's not that good and this is
consistent with all the hotels until
they have to get to the same point this
is 10.
so
my question was that
do users know about this bias
and how they behave around that like
what how they make sense of this
algorithmic impact on their interaction
with the system
so i first needed to find if users were
aware of this to understand their
behavior so i kind of resorted to my own
experience so the way i found about this
bias
was that i was at the beginning of my
phd i was on low budget i wanted to go
to conferences so my advisor said if you
find a place that is not really
expensive i'm going to send you even you
don't have a paper
and i was new to the us so i went on
booking.com and i saw a motel 6 that
have a 7.5 rating and i said people say
model 6 is bad how bad it could be
so and i'm really flexible so i thought
i just want to go to conference so i
went there
and
uh
you know it wasn't an easy
like experience because everything
stopped working i didn't have air
conditioner i didn't have fridge like it
was noisy i couldn't sleep the whole
like three nights i was there so even
i'm not that much of a reviewer i went
there and i wrote a review and i tried
to give everything the lowest but i
could not
so i was so angry so i started doing
this research and i found this and it
was during my own research on this
socio-technical system
so i thought that maybe some people had
the same experience maybe they tried to
give it something lowest or at least
some score that they expected to be
there and they could not so
what i did is that i started looking at
ratings of people
and looking at the reviews if i saw they
mentioned something like bias or talking
about something miscalculation or mis uh
interpretation and i found uh
one about 160 people and they actually
many of them had a higher score of 2.5
but they still became aware of this bias
and
uh
as i'm going to show you here what
resulted in this awareness was a
mismatch between the review score and
their expectations similar to my
experience so this person even is 7.5
this person did not want to say
that this hotel is this good so but they
got the score calculated by the
algorithm
and i started analyzing these users
comments like they on on the website to
see how they behaved around the system
so
what i found is that they use their
reviews which were supposed to be about
the hotel stay
to raise awareness about the problem of
the system itself so other than just
talking about the hotel only they were
talking about the booking.com and how it
manipulated users experience to show bad
hotels better that people can go and
uh purchase them
and they did that through uh three
kinds of practices so
first they tried to look into the black
box which is kind of normal i did the
same
they said that like for example i looked
at what the score your algorithm comes
up if i give everything the lowest and
it still comes to 2.5 rather than 0 1
which sounds that the range is
manipulated
and then they tried to fix the algorithm
by their own way so they could not fix
anything in terms of the calculation but
try they try to use their review to
announce the real score so this goal
that algorithm calculated was there but
they said like for example look my score
is not 8.8 it's actually something about
seven in my mind or some actually try to
change the technical technical parts of
the algorithm like for example this
person they could not go under 2.5 but
at least if they wanted to give
something like like three but it gave
eight like this person they tried to
change other responses to get to the
lowest score that they can
and
this reflects actually previous research
that they call it fixing
or repairing the systems when users use
improvisations to fix the system when
they cannot actually change the outputs
of the system
and finally some users stated that how
much heartbroken they were with the
booking.com particularly some of them
that use the system
a lot but they never wrote a review to
understand this biases
it like this person telling other users
that do not trust the systems and some
actually said that they're not going to
use the website again because of this
bias and assuming that they might be
also other manipulations at work
so
through all these actions from trying to
look into the black box to fix the
algorithm or actually letting others
know about this problem
what these users were actually doing
were adding seams
like some visibilities to the system to
give others some awareness about what's
going on
for example when they say like
using your title like the system needs
to give a 2.5 lower than 2.5 i did one
let me
they tried to
use this
as increasing visibility to the system
for other users and this manual practice
actually
is analogous to a practice that we use
in design and this was suggested by
researchers as a practical design
suggestion which is called simple design
meaning that when you have a black box
systems you can add visit
invisible hints disclosing some aspects
of the automation process if you see
there is some misinformed behavior going
on
so i ask that when users see a need for
a simple design or adding seams to a
system when it doesn't work properly why
we as researchers or developers of the
systems don't do so in sociotechnical
systems using algorithms
so
the question here was that where to add
seams how much seams like how much
visibility we want to add to the systems
so
to answer that i turn to another rating
platform which is also in famous for
my having a potential bias in its
algorithm yelp which i believe most of
you know it's a business trading system
again for most restaurants
and
this time i used yell because yelp
actually provides an extra opportunity
compared to other review platforms for
users which is a from inside yet that
users can discuss things so in
booking.com users only had their reviews
as the only way to comment on the
algorithm but yeah actually provides a
way that people can talk about and it's
supposed to talk about your experience
going to restaurants or businesses
but users i found that users actually
use this
system to talk about the algorithm
itself
so we collected uh hundreds of this post
from over seven years from many users
and analyzed them qualitatively to
understand what's users demand what they
change in terms of where to add seams
we found that users talked about two
types of bias in this algorithmic system
on year so yield rating algorithm if you
know about that what it does is a bit
different it filters some reviews so
it's kind of a zero or so it gives ways
to reviews it's either zero or one if
it's zero it's not calculated in the
business reading if it's one it's just
all calculated so it's a bit different
from amazon but it works in this way so
many people talked about the bias in its
operation selling telling like
that yelp actually
filters
the good reviews of businesses
that don't
advertise video or on the other side if
you advertise video it filters your bad
reviews that you goes to the like
filtered page that users don't say yeah
just make sure i understand is this what
yelp actually does that they will filter
the negative the positive ones unless
you have to it's just a compliment it
has like more of 700 lawsuits
they could never
like approve or like approv they never
proved anything but what happened is
that many business makers like hundreds
of them
actually said that they got calls from
yelp that says if you
do advertising with us we are gonna
like filter your negative reviews so
that's just a complaint it took many
years helped settle that but the still
people are talking about that that they
got a lot of calls
and then um this was one that many
people talked about that
and yelp is the only one actually in
famous for that so but we don't know its
potential or not the other one which
actually shows something that is not
potential it's actually there is the
bias in algorithm's existence so if you
are a yelp user and your review is
filtered
it's actually
when you are logged in with yelp it's
gonna show that you your review of
yourself as recommended to the user who
wrote that
but all the other users or if you are
not even logged in as a guest
will see your review as filtered
so meaning that if you're a user you're
not going to get to know that your
review is actually filtered which made
people actually angrier because they
thought that there is a kind of a
deception going on here
so i'm not going to talk about all the
details of this part of this study but
i'm going to just uh
turn your attention to one expect like a
specific theme that we found
is that we found that many users
question the algorithm either the
operation or the existence of and
deception and that but there were many
users actually defended the algorithm
they had they had arguments like for
example yelp needs to make this
algorithm opaque because if it doesn't
make opaque people are going to game the
system or like uh
like other other ideas that they try to
convince other users it was kind of a
discussion that say elf is doing a good
job
but
what we found is that
when everyone had either questioned or
defended
the existence the opacity in existence
the operation or opacity and operation
of the algorithm no one
actually particularly defended the
opacity in existence meaning that while
users said okay yeah the algorithm
should be there
the algorithm should work it ways or the
algorithm should be opaque in how it
works no one said that the algorithm
should be opaque it's in presence
meaning that yelp should not hide from
users that there is an algorithm at work
and this actually led us to
kind of the start of the design of the
systems meaning that at the first step
users need to know there is an algorithm
at work and then we should go the next
step that how much we want to reveal to
them
so
this leads the
second part of the talk which is about
now how we want to design for users to
give them
some information about the presence of
an algorithm and then help them to
understand how the algorithm works to
get some uh sense making process
done
and
i'm going to talk about
two simple designs here
that uh during my phd i i've built with
help of my colleagues
and uh
one of them is feedback which is uh
about facebook news situation algorithm
which shows users that if there was no
algorithm at work filtering their feed
what post they would see so kind of
showing them the hidden posts and also
reveal which is about the yelp algorithm
we just discussed
and showing users which reviews of them
were actually filtered that they could
not see other than they log out or log
in from another user uh today i'm going
to just focus on feed these the results
we got from feed visa and reveal by
exposing users with today's algorithms
impact very similar so i'm going to
focus on feedback mainly
so feed this as i said revealed to users
the differences in their feeds if it was
if it was not curated by the facebook
newsfeed curation algorithm and to build
feed these i used a facebook api which
during that time actually allowed me to
extract all the stories of
all users
all of a friends of a user and then
compared with the user's newsfeed to see
which of those stories actually appeared
on the feed or not
and then with that
i uh designed like i did like a lab
study trying to see how users interacted
with this
interface how much
they could make sense of the algorithm
by understanding what was filtered and
what was not
and
one thing that i found at the beginning
which was kind of surprised
surprising was that many of the users in
this study did not know that their field
was filtered they thought that whatever
they uh oh sorry they thought that
whatever they
whatever their friends posted on
facebook appeared on their news so if
they missed that it's because maybe they
scrolled past them or they just did not
log in enough to look at them
and then i started
uh investigating that why these people
did not know there is an algorithm some
of them were using facebook for 10 years
so
we looked at their activity and
understanding like if the activity
between those who were aware and on a
very different and we found that those
who were actively engaged with the
platform meaning that when something
happened they did not they did not like
see a friend's post for a while they
went to their page and checked and said
they were some post missing or they post
themselves a post on facebook and saw
that it didn't like enough comments or
likes they ask their friends what's
going on those types of people were more
prone to be aware of the algorithm on
the other hand those who were passively
engaged they were less prone to be a
behavior of the algorithm because those
people did not have any posting activity
or talking with other friends they just
read the platform even read the feed
even they did not bother to go to
another first page to see if they
checked anything yeah
how often they went to the site it's
just whether they were posting versus
they were concerned actually it was like
kind of eight features one of them was
how often they went to the side
uh which showed that that doesn't matter
it was kind of a passive engagement the
main active engagement was if they were
business owners because they also had a
lot of cues that something is not like
not shown to everybody if they the
posting activity was one of them if they
um control their feet like they said i
don't want to see to hide this or not
like those guys are more active
engagements but but uh visiting their
website wasn't passive
i remember your sample was uh like a
pretty sort of broad set you tried to
get out of that yeah
real people not cs people yeah and lily
so
what was the rough distribution of
active versus passive among oh
i think it was for about 40 60. so 60
were passive 40 were active
but uh
and it was very correlated with being
aware or not aware of this
up there
so
when we found about this lack of
awareness we started walking people to
feed this we wanted to know that how
feed these and particularly for those
who were not aware of the algorithm
exposing them to these
algorithms existing and its effects can
change their attitude or understanding
of the system so first we showed them
content view which is showing them what
is filtered or not so on the right side
you see shown stories which is their
real regular feed all the stories the
white ones are like like holes in their
feed were ones that they were actually
filtered and we showed to them
and then we showed them a friend view
meaning that we told them which friends
were rarely shown on their feet were
mostly shown or some sometimes shown on
their feet
and when we expose users to these views
those who
did not know about this algorithmic
extent
kind of uh very surprised or actually
like this one said that it's like waking
up in the matrix like whole my whole
life like 10 years i was using facebook
and i didn't know that they're
controlling my feet
and uh
one of these reactions particularly
those who were dissatisfied
was
because of the reveal because of the
misperceptions were revealed meaning
that there were people who did not get
anything from a friend and they thought
that the friend filtered them and they
never went to that friend's page to see
that was actually visible to them that
was just a
controlling algorithm that did that uh
prop that uh change in their feed
and uh this person particularly actually
left facebook at the end of the study he
was so angry he sent this email that i'm
not if the trust is broken but we never
seen like that such kind of extreme
behavior
but that can happen because of mistrust
to the system
and
then after they explored their feed with
or without the algorithms in
interference we told them okay assume
that you could change your feet what
would you do so we told them to
particularly if they want to see a story
who it was hidden or vice versa they
mark it and also the same for friends if
they wanted to move their friends
between groups
and interestingly we found that people
move their friends
three times almost three times more than
their content
they said that they care about friends
post being there it doesn't matter what
kind of post is it like for example they
said it's my brother he says happy
birthday to someone i know it doesn't
matter but it's my brother i want to be
there so it shows that
social media is still in many of these
particularly the friendship
type of social media people care more
about the people rather than the content
they post
and
what we found at the end of the study
was interesting because while people
came with all of this dissatisfaction
and being angry
and yelling at facebook at the end of
the day when they started to see all
this filtered stuff they said that
they're kind of getting the sense that
why this algorithm is there and if it
was not there it would just clutter up
what they really want to see so the
question here is that why
if
these people wanted this algorithm they
were
why they are not aware of this and how
how becoming aware of this algorithm can
change their behavior so what we did it
wasn't a controlled experiment so we
could not actually see how this changed
but what we did was a follow-up with
users two to six months after this study
we asked them if after this study they
changed anything
and we found that many of these users
change their engagement with the system
in in different and sometimes
interesting ways so
for example they started to manipulate
the manipulator meaning that they said
that for example now i know if you click
on like it's going to show more of this
person to me or more of this topic so
i'm going to be selective
and some of these people may not change
their behavior but they change their
emotions for example the person said i
feel less snug when i post something and
no one likes or comments or just a few
people i think this is the algorithm
that doesn't show it to enough people
it's not my friends
and
still people had same or higher
satisfaction with the system this shows
that other than the extreme cases that
the kind of their trust was broken with
the system they showed that if you
provide some visibility to the system it
still can help users to be satisfied
with the system but become more engaged
and intelligent users
and i'm happy that a few months ago
facebook actually
added this why am i saying this post i
encourage you to check and see you you
are on that list of users who get that
or not i'm still not getting this but it
gives you some information about why you
are seeing this
and shows you that not everything is
there so giving you some hints about
that
but the question here is that
we know that sinful design could be
helpful and we have transparency on the
other side that everything is
transparent
but how much transparency we need like
do we want a system be fully transparent
or if not how much we want to add
transparency to the system
and transparency is actually a complex
problem transparency is a sweet word but
it comes with a lot of uh costs for
example
explaining an algorithm in a simple way
is really hard even for the developers
of the system
and
users interaction with the system will
become cooper some if you want to
overwhelm them with the machine learning
algorithm with hundreds of thousands of
factors
and even if it's possible people are
going to use that to game the system no
matter
uh what the system is there are always
gamers gaming the system
so
to understand like if there is a
practical way to help users to
understand what's going on in the system
without interfering the interaction with
the system in the last part of my talk
i'm going to talk about
designing for algorithm transparency
and it's about how we can add visibility
to the operation of the algorithm not
just the presence of an algorithm
and i'm going to turn my attention to
online behavioral advertising algorithms
because they received a lot of attention
during previous years as you see here
this is my facebook page but these are
the ads i get
and as you see it's because i i searched
the boss baby for my new my niece
and my husband is looking for all of all
over the internet and our accounts are
connected
so i kind of have an idea what's going
on in this system like boy i got this
ads but there are many times that you
get an ad and you just wonder why i got
this ad is this anything related to me
is it random and
it's
it's not something simple and average
online users believe it or not if you
turn off your ad blocker
send you about 11 000 online ads per
month which is not something that you
can just trivial that you can just
ignore but the question is that
how you get these ads you distill some
of them are obvious like the ones i
showed you but there are many of them
that you use your data and you don't
know how this uh algorithms work and
this has caused privacy concerns
mistrust and a large satisfaction among
users
so
resulting in calls for algorithmic
transparency
because of these opacities many
users ask that for the firmware
understanding what's going on with the
system in advertising
researchers also argue that users need
openness with these marketers about how
an
ad is targeted to a user and if you
heard about gdpr it's a couple years
that europe european regulations
actually
make these systems to give users an
explanation about an algorithmic
decision including advertisers
so
what we did in this study to understand
what we need to give users in terms of
transparency we evaluated some existing
transparency mechanisms in online
behavioral advertising
helping users
trying to understand users uh in terms
of their needs about transparency
and we did the participatory and
speculative design tasks meaning that we
also asked users to design their desired
level of transparency
so
we exposed users to three views in an
advertising system
which is what a user sees what an
advertising algorithm says and what an
advertiser says in terms of what the
user sees
we show them their real ads we ask them
to bring their personal device
like browse their real as and look if
there is an explanation about why they
are seeing that and then explore the
explanation
then we expose them to what an
advertising algorithm knows about them
and with that we actually showed them
a few views that some advertising
companies
choose to show to users in terms of the
interests
or uh like uh
hobbies or interests they have
uh that they inferred from there using
the system so this is for example is the
facebook advertising uh preference view
and as you see they inferred a lot of
things about me which like some of them
are right like i love kittens i had a
lot of them
but some of them are interesting oops
like this dental floss you see here
i'm so famous in my family with liking
the tofus and overusing them i have
backup for backups in my backpack you
can see two of them but i've never
searched online for dental floss i've
never even purchased one at all and i
have no idea how facebook found it and
why it just categorized that interest so
i encourage you to explore this that has
funny or interesting
interests that it's going to show you
and finally we showed them the
advertiser view meaning that we told
them how an advertiser gets to target an
audience and here on facebook because
facebook has the most complex
uh advertising with like uh interface
more than 29 000 categories that they
can use to target users and like we walk
them through some of these like show
them what kind of details they can
target
and then we engage them in a speculative
design task meaning that we told them
now
choose a product of interest you want to
buy in the next month
use the advertising interface
to target an audience for that product
but make sure that when you target the
audience they are people like you
meaning that if you post this ad on
facebook you are gonna get this ad
and then we ask them to write an
explanation for this ad as well telling
them that if you get this exp this ad
and you click on why am i seeing this at
what you want to see what do you want to
see
the reason we did this was that
now users because they are the tar they
are the advertisers themselves they know
the exact reasons why this ad was
targeted they have full transparency so
we wanted to know how much they want to
actually use in the explanation
so i'm going to start talking about
first
the evaluation of the current existing
current existing transparency mechanisms
and how they reflected those in their
design of their own desired
transparency so first
we found that users like interpretable
explanation which is no surprise
so if it's an explanation it's like that
this ad has been matched to your
interest it was based on your browsing
activity as users that it's a black box
it doesn't give you anything other than
just
trying maybe to
not uh
not want you to make like mess with the
system
on the other side on the other side
there were some uh specific explanations
that actually people liked for example
this says facebook for developers wants
to reach people who have visited this
page
so kind of giving you some specific
explanation what's going on or you if
you're in this demographic so people
like this because they said they
understand them better
but we found that there is something
about
having enough transparency not full
transparency
and it's about having a linkage to
identity i'm going to explain you here
so when we ask users to design the
desired level of transparency about the
ad that has got the target to themselves
we saw that when they choose for example
here like eight or nine categories
they choose just a few of this to put
into explanation like for example this
was a four video game this person this
person chose
young and hip video games and electronic
music
and when we asked and this is just an
example most of the participants were
like this when we asked them why you
don't have the complete explanation well
you just do not list everything here
they said that i wanted like categories
are more cultural related to me rather
than just a full transparency that's
going to make me overwhelmed this does
not mean that we don't want to provide
users with full transparency it means
that if you want to have a design that
doesn't get in the way of users you
might need some kind of enough
transparency for example in advertising
is about if it has some cultural or
linkage to the user's identity but they
still give them a way if they want to
explore full
transparency and
i'm going to also show you here in more
detail what this linkage to identity
mean in advertising so when users
explored their inferred interest by the
algorithm
when they saw a feature that they were
proud of they were they're kind of happy
they were satisfied with the algorithm
like this person
but if they saw
a feature that they were not happy with
like this late technology adopter label
many of them actually became angry like
this person was trying to convince me
that every time something new comes out
i get that why it labeled me as a late
technology adopter we have all the new
stuff at home
so it sounds like if the algorithm
infers something wrong about you that
you cared about people did not like that
and
if the explanation like this one had a
link
to the to the user's identity they liked
it because they said that the algorithm
inferred it
and actually went an extra mile to show
it that to me
and
if it did not this or showed something
was wrong people did not were not happy
with the explanation and even a full
transparency would not make them happy
and
this concept of enough transparency
something in between is not new in
another research study a few years ago
it was shown for another type of
algorithm that if the students are
getting exposed to too much or too
little transparency about how and a
grading algorithm uh calculated their
their gear is they're not going to be
satisfied with the system so they just
need some level of transparency that
makes them understand the system without
getting in their way
and with that
i hope that they could show you
that if you have a sinful design adding
some visibility to the system but with
enough transparency we can actually help
users to become more informed and
intelligent when they are interacting
with the system
and with that i want to encourage us
like as researchers as developers or
future developers of the systems that
when you write a code
or when you design a system consider
this that the user who are sitting on
the other side of the computer and using
these algorithms it's going to affect
their life small or large it's going to
affect their life and they have the
right to know what's going on but we
have to design and build the systems in
a way to help them not interfere with
them
and i'm going to finish
with this example a few years ago like
not a few it's kind of six years ago
when i started my phd i got this
question a lot that we use cars our cars
have engines and we never need to know
what's going on with our cars engines
and we are fine
and what's the difference here why we
need to get some visibility to these
opaque algorithmic systems we are just
working with them it's like our cars we
get the information and just move on
with our life it took me actually many
years to get a good answer to that
but there are two differences one is
that when your car breaks you know it's
broken
but when the algorith an algorithm in a
system breaks you don't know it might be
biased it might be biased for many years
it might affect people's life if they
know even if they know or not but you
don't know it's broken and
in addition when your car breaks you
take it to a mechanic it's just that
simple but who are the mechanics of the
topic algorithmic systems when an
algorithm makes some mistakes no one
even feels the authority to question the
algorithm's decision but if there is
visibility into the system it can help
the users of those systems particularly
in the highest stake situations like the
example i brought
i i gave you at the beginning of the
talk that users give users have the
confidence to work with the system and
change the decision if it's necessary
and with that i want to thank you all
for listening to me and i'd be happy to
take questions
yeah i was wondering how
you're saying like that enough
transparency is having that recognizable
length to identity but how do they do
that in a way where people are satisfied
like very liberal might not make people
proud like you're saying so like how do
you feel
i think um yeah you're right maybe there
are features that some people are proud
of or some people are not proud of and
that's actually only in the context of
advertising i even don't know what other
context might
look like i think
the best thing is not i mean this is a
kind of a controversial because some
people might say maybe we show something
that is a lie but people are happy with
that so i'm not advocating for that i'm
just saying that if the algorithm makes
a mistake and it's about the feature you
like they're not going to like it so one
thing is definitely increasing the
algorithms
accuracy but one other thing we found is
that showing people that algorithms make
mistake that if it is happening because
people in the studies we've done we
found that people kind of uh trust the
algorithms objectively they think that
what they decide is just all true and
that makes them sad or upset but when
they started seeing more and more
mistakes in the system it didn't make
them
uh
that dissatisfied like when there was no
mistake so i think it should be both
increasing the accuracy and also helping
users to understand
uh how algorithms work
yeah
like they kind of like being surprised
you know when the actual facebook is
showing them less content about their
friends that they you have to care about
but like why do you think the algorithm
actually fails to uh pick that up right
like if you're using that potentially
due to something going on the survey
that people are actually not telling
what they
you've been failing and not knowing
there's an algorithm at work no like i
don't want to like why do you think like
when people say like they do care a lot
about their friends post but why do you
think like their behaviors on the
platform they don't really reflect that
i think it's because of the lack of
feedback to the system
like for example uh many of them did not
know there is an algorithm so they never
never even tried to give feedback to the
algorithm for example if they did not
the algorithm did not show a friend for
a while they give feedback and i think
that's because also i don't know if you
notice there's the most most recent and
top stories on the side of your facebook
which is most recent is supposed to be
non filtered or at least less filtered
than top stories but facebook default is
top of stories and whenever you try to
switch to most recent it comes back so
people were stuck on that default and
they had no idea that they can provide
feedback feedback so i think that makes
algorithm to go to a negative loop and
just fails and fails more
that's a good question
any other questions
okay
so
you you're positing essentially some
sort of functional relationship between
the algorithmic complexity and people's
understanding
and trust
um so like if i sort of there's the
algorithmic complexity people's
understanding of that complexity and
then trust is sort of like three layers
here i'm trying to sort of understand a
bit what you think is that functional
relationship for example um
in a project we did
any sort of algorithm that was more
complicated than something very basic
was immediately like
just
there was a bit flip and people just
said this is crazy and i don't trust it
um
and yet you also have some results that
you're showing that like people that
there's this notion of enough
transparency that like i don't need to
fully understand it
but i sort of gotta i get a rough folk
theory of this
so i'm wondering like
okay
so what are we to do right
is it true would you agree that anything
that's more than sort of like a basic
you know like loop structure is
basically
unexplainable in sort of the in in the
limit um in the same way that we you
know the supreme court doesn't allow
gerrymandering algorithms that are that
cannot be easily understood like do you
think that there's just some fundamental
limit that you know it has to be either
dead simple like chronological or no
one's gonna get it
uh and if and then as part of it like
now we have you're positing this sort of
intermediate zone where i sort of like
can hand wave sort of
a high level of it to create a folk
theory
and is that a solution or is that like
actually just burying the problem more i
think it's the mitigation i think it
helps like users get some idea of the
presence of an algorithm which is the
first step i think the complexity goes
when we want to explain the operation of
the algorithm which is like the
existence is not really hard like you
can add things here and they're telling
them that there is an algorithm at work
but for the operation i think there
there is a like rich line of literature
in terms of explainable ai or like how i
think most of these work for expert
users for delay users as you said if it
goes a bit higher than basic they don't
understand that so i think the solution
i think i don't know if the solution or
just mitigating the problem
is that
we always try to provide like there
should be some and that goes that
actually can happen only with
regulations i don't think it's good
there should be a wait for full
transparency at least if there is if and
if there's a gaming problem with the
system it could be like maybe visible
full fully transparent to those who
regulate the systems but for basic users
i think
this is a fundamental issue you can't
teach users like how a neural network
works and it's not because of those
relay users even a developer of a system
like i write a code and i don't know
what's going on in the code like it just
goes to little functions and return
functions and it's just hard to explain
so i think there might be some
help to make it easier but i think at
the end of the day users need to build
and whatever users read as folk theories
they're going to act on that so i think
what we need to make sure is that we
give them some basic explanations and
make sure they are not building folk
theories that are wrong or at least if
they are wrong they are not interrupting
their informed interaction with the
system like for example if they build a
theory that for example we had this oil
like uh like kind of algorithms are all
powerful or all-knowing they consider
like facebook as a spy and things like
that it's just gonna interfere with the
interaction with the system
like you're looking at yelp right the
problem with the yelp algorithm isn't
like it didn't seem like
transparency is itself the issue it's
that the transparency makes me feel less
trustful of sort of the the the justness
of the outcome
and in the same way like imagine now
you're gonna be teaching soon like okay
i could say i'm going to curve this this
exam okay so then we're going to like
you know take the mean standard
deviations okay there's that i could i
could do something more complicated
where i like weight the more recent
assignments than more or something like
this and then it starts to get a little
bit more opaque and all the way at the
end i'd be like i'm going to train a
neural network based on past performance
that's going to predict your ability to
succeed in the upper division class
right which of these would you use you
know even if i'm giving you the
existence of this like i feel like
there's some hard trade-off that we're
making i think yeah i think you're i i
actually even after seven years working
on this i've never get like kind of an
one answer for all like i think it
really depends on the system on the
context but i think
it's
it's going to be like what i think if i
would do that is that you first need to
try and see which of these work and try
to and i didn't get to talk about folk
theories much but extract the folk
theories extracting how people think
about the system how much to trust and
then revise the explanations but i
honestly don't think it's going to solve
the problem as you said is
it's prob also as a problem of justice
of the system that needs maybe
regulations on the other side so but
that's the part on the user side you can
never get everyone
happy but you can get maybe
some information and more people yeah
yeah so
i'm curious along these lines is an
explanation enough or
do you also need to provide mechanisms
for the users to
change
yeah actually that's kind of an area
it's called contestability of the
algorithms like
trying to give feedback and change i
think they should work together so just
to transparency without
giving users control
oh i think for example currently like in
advertising it says like we infer these
interests for you are you happy or not
and you can click and change them so
that goes as a feedback to the system
and change i don't know how how much
they change the algorithm for that but
giving users a sense of control
if they had if they had told you why you
were on that list but didn't give you
any mechanisms for for getting off that
one you were yeah what would you do
actually there was a recent research
that i think one of my colleagues is uh
uh things that stop measuring but i
think i'm okay to talk about that much
that they found that if you if like
explanation without contestability or
appeal is not enough people are not
happy particularly the decision you're
not the decision that you're not you you
don't agree with but they found that if
you give contestability but they don't
think that the contestability actually
is real or helpful
it doesn't help for example if they yeah
that don't reverse because they think
that for example if you like for example
if facebook flags you as a fake user and
you get a chance but they say it's gonna
do this whatever it wants nobody and
hears me it's just
if they don't get the real sense of
control no it doesn't help but yeah
definitely if i if someone told me that
why i'm on the list
maybe they thought that i'm going to try
to convince them or like appeal that
maybe they didn't want to go there but i
think these are two the other hand to
hand so you can't have explanation
without appeals or like contestability
it's gonna give
it might even make people less satisfied
with the system
you